hey guys it is the tenth of October my
name's Justin you're watching games but
news it's been announced the squadron 42
the standalone single player game
spinoff from star citizen has been
delayed the game was originally set to
be a mode with in star citizen before
being spun off on its own it was slated
to come out this year but will now be
arriving sometime next year creator
chris Roberts said they wanted to do the
game right particularly in light of the
127 million dollars raised through
crowdfunding to enable them to make it
in the first place Roberts explained as
much as we wanted to have squadron 42
for this year it's not going to be this
year because from the Polish we need to
do it still needs a bit more time for
those that are disappointed Roberts has
said they'll be showing a completed
polished mission in the near future
hopefully before the years out in
exciting news we might have a better
idea of when Mass Effect Andromeda is
coming out an Amazon listing has been
released for Dark Horse Comics tie-in
art book the art of Mass Effect
Andromeda the book carries a release
date of March 21 2017 and the
description on the listing notes of the
art book will be coming out
simultaneously with the game so strong
likelihood that the 21st of March is
indeed the day a new trailer is on its
way for + 7 day on november seven which
Bioware have said will officially open
the doors to the next chapter of the
Mass Effect universe I live with us to
have announced the file sizes and PC
system requirements are for the skyrim
remaster Bethesda has revealed that the
remastered version of Skyrim has gone
gold meaning development is all wrapped
up and it's ready to go the recommended
level PC system specs call for an i5
2400 or FX 8320 and a GTX 780 or r9 290
so Rob ibly nothing you can't handle
you'll also need 12 gigabytes of hard
drive space free on behalf of all you'll
need 20 gigabytes free for the north
american version and 33 gigabytes for
the european version presumably due to
the need to
include more languages on an xbox one
it's 17 gigabytes for the US and twenty
five gigabytes for Europe Skyrim special
edition launches on October 28 and it's
free for those on PC who owned the
original and it's 3 DLC packs all
versions including ps4 will support mods
you can check out the full list of
system specs in our story on gamespot
that is everything I've got for you
monday do head to gamespot for stories
on pray and gears of war and i'll catch
you again tomorrow